President Barack Obama took his healthcare reform plan on the road...
...and to the people.
Hello everybody!
This town hall meeting in Ohio comes at a time when congress is struggling to agree...
...on a way to pay for a plan to reform America's healthcare.
The estimated price tag: one trillion dollars.
I won't sign it if that reform adds even one dime to our deficit over the next decade...
...and I mean what I say.
The president is pushing for a plan that will prevent insurance companies from dropping coverage,...
...he also wants limits on out-of-pocket cost.
Bills in the house and senate would require most businesses to provide health insurance for their employees,...
...all Americans would also have to get health insurance.
Discounts would be available for anyone who can't afford it.
Cancer survivor Angela Kegwell McDowell says she can't get insurance even if she can afford it...
...because of her pre-existing condition.
I'm too high of a risk...
...so no matter how much I could afford,...
...I cannot get insurance right now through our system.
You won't have to worry about pre-existing conditions...
...because never again will anyone in America be denied coverage,...
...because of a previous illness or injury.